Netflix might have a lot to offer but
critics aren't crazy about all of their
originals while we beg to differ
in fact there's a lot to love when it
comes to some of the streaming services
less than critically acclaimed fare
here's a reappraisal of the Netflix
series that critics were totally wrong
about Vanity Fair posited that girlboss
might have been Netflix's first truly
terrible show a smug summation of
Millennials at their worst embodied by
supposed heroine and wannabe mogul
Sophia Amoruso it didn't help that the
real-life Amoruso
CEO of online fashion retailer Nasty Gal
was catching flack for her business
practices as the show premiered girlboss
wasn't just bad it was badly timed as
well according to critics at least you
can do this you do not want a bad review
a bad review if - but the show on its
own is a whip-smart delight critics
slammed the fictionalized Amoruso for
being imperfect accusing her character
of being vapid and narcissistic the
reality is simpler this is a show about
a person being as messy and fallible as
people often are audiences don't care if
a Moroso makes mistakes in fact that's
why they're watching we love it in don
draper we love it in Walter White and we
love it in Sophia Amoruso she's a brat
sure she's ruthless bring it on we're
not here for a lesson we're here for a
story and girlboss delivers with drama
and style to spare oh did I just detect
the tiniest gleam of interest on your
face this impassioned biopic chronicles
the controversial life and death of
Madalyn Murray O'Hair the founder of the
American Atheists and the leader of the
push to take prayer out of public
schools I better start a damn brand cuz
we're gonna take this all the way to
Supreme Court if we have to critics
called it disjointed and unfocused
claiming that it ping-ponged crazily
between comedy tragedy and points in
between this isn't entirely untrue the
most hated woman in America plays fast
and loose with the audience's
expectations but the reality is that
O'Hare's life which included legal
victories family drama and untimely and
violent death was just as bizarre and
prone to wild shifts anchored by melissa
leo stirring performance it is a film as
utterly unique as its subject a journey
from deep love to towering pride and all
that comes from the collision of those
two fundamental forces Oh
haier resist categorization she's
neither the triumphant Crusader nor the
sneering witch this movie honors that
and chooses to live in the volatile
in-between where she can be the person
she was frustrating contradictory and
driven by unshakable conviction
chloë grace moretz plays Susanna
kuhaylan
in this terrifying descent in the
medical turmoil based on the real-life
Kalin's battle with anti-nmda receptor
encephalitis her symptoms are harrowing
and sudden sending her into periods of
rage paranoia and extreme sensitivity
that seemed to have no cause doctors
suggest all manner of incorrect
diagnosis as Kaelyn sinks further and
further into abject suffering grabbing
desperately at remedies for exhaustion
schizophrenia and sleep deprivation
critics claimed the movie relied too
heavily on cliches which means they're
probably ignoring the fact that kuhaylan
story really did end with an
eleventh-hour deus ex machina the moment
the right doctor identified the illness
ravaging her brain and the relatively
straightforward road to recovery it led
her on
beyond this however is Moretz --is
underrated performance which veers
wildly as a character's brain careens
more and more off-track brain on fire
ends with an unlikely victory but it's
first and foremost a story about illness
the way it can destabilize a life the
way it launches sufferers into a strange
and scary new world of uncertainty and
the way it can be solved by the
unlikeliest confluence of fate this
adaptation of Ellen Montgomery's beloved
Anne of Green Gables series has proved
divisive to say the least
longtime fans and critics alike
condemned its darkness rather than
leaving Anne's traumatic childhood
behind it examines how her experiences
might have shaped her in the form of
flashbacks and panic attacks
moreover characters like Gilbert Blythe
and love interest and Matthew and
Marilla the brother and sister who
become parents to Anne are given
entirely original subplots of their own
critics argue that these additions are
unnecessary at best needlessly grim at
worst no one returns to Aunt Shirley's
adventures for pathos they argue they
what they already love you know too well
the impact of an untimely death Anna
suffered so much loss the vast majority
of the series is faithful to Montgomery
starry-eyed vision and loses herself in
the pleasures of friendship raspberry
cordial and teaching other orphans to
read this adaptation is merely
interested in examining the hardships
that make the cheery moments possible
all we can do is our best Marilla
regardless of what we know or don't know
she truly loved this chronicle of a
1930s Iowa farmers strike was derided by
critics for feeling overlong and more
than a little like homework while it
might not be everyone's cup of tea for
the connoisseur of historical drama
damnation is anything but dull it's a
brutal story to be sure and it doesn't
offer hope without reason in a world
crowded with happy-go-lucky hobos riding
trains to rock candy mountain there is a
need for a show as dark and tone as
damnation you seem to be shooting at
your chickens it's our dinner with them
can't afford to lose more eggs the
writing is strong the performance is
passionate and the drama is rooted in a
real American struggle that goes to this
day it is in fact very much in line with
the American tradition of flinty I'd
worker stories if it's grim it's because
it's telling the truth and there is
always room for the truth in our
adaptations of the past check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell see you
don't miss a single one
[Applause]
you
[Applause]
[Music]